nearly done the 980 million dollar las
vegas convention center expansion
just pretty close to being ready for the
public now it's just a matter of the lvc
va getting more major shows and
conventions back to town
bianca holman live this afternoon with
an update on tourism from this morning's
meeting bianca
yeah lots of approvals during this
meeting and matter of fact something
we've all been waiting for a sneak peek
inside that new wing of the convention
center
so we got a look inside so here are some
pictures and videos that the lvcva
shared with us
and this is into the new wing of the
convention center
it includes the born companies terminals
and various event spaces
of the floor plan there the board also
and you can see that it is just an
incredible site the board also approves
several events for the second half of
the year
big crowd pleasers like the life is
beautiful downtown rock concert series
and the pbr they all have the green
light to move forward
lv cva's president and ceo steve hill
says that
the increased access to the vaccine is a
step in the right direction
i think we have the opportunity to open
everything back up
people can start to make their own
choices and
we can get the meetings and convention
industry
industry back we can get our tourism and
hospitality back
and really be close to back to normal
so in preparation for the return of
summer and fall conventions and
events hill says they are slowly
bringing back staff members
and also even though some of those big
events are downtown mayor carolyn
goodman she says
moreheads in beds benefit the entire
valley
reporting from the convention center
bianca holman 8 news now